now that looks really gross but think it
through with me now you can clearly see
it doesn't exist at x equals zero right
because you're gonna have division by
zero so it breaks but X is not simply
the denominator so you're not going to
get a vertical asymptote if that's this
denominator you can never equal zero
right because if it was to equal zero we
have this right being equal to zero so
yeah so then you like on a second and
then you go through some power and I
raised to that power I get a negative
number if you remember from logs no such
number exists so therefore this
denominator will never equal 0 so this
whole function will not have a vertical
asymptote so what does that look like
alright now this is a really good
example of thinking about the two kinds
of limits that we were looking at before
from above and from below okay so think
with me for a minute yes we do it but I
still don't know what it's actually
doing there right I don't have a
vertical asymptote it was something else
the question is what is it
so I want to think about what's this
thing doing as I approach zero from the
right hand side okay so
what's it doing all right well as X
approaches your from the right hand side
what kind of numbers am I thinking of
okay from the right hand side I'm
actually getting closer and closer is a
limit to zero right so I'm actually can
give very small numbers that are
positive there the numbers on the right
hand side okay
so numbers like say oh I don't know
numbers like say point 1 and point zero
one zero point zero zero one so I'm
approaching what's happening towards the
origin but from this side okay so think
with me okay what am I gonna get as I
put numbers like that yeah
point one it's just equivalent to the
power of point one well I started one
over point one okay so let's think about
this I'm just thinking at this one
little component here okay this is going
to be to the power of one over zero
point one right which is actually to the
power of ten okay which is a thousand
and twenty four thousand 24 right good
same so on the bottom here I've got a
thousand 25 okay
what irva yeah okay what kind of number
is that it's very very very small right
what's gonna happen as I approach this
yeah that's right this is gonna be to
the power of a hundred okay which I
don't know what that is but it'll be
very large number okay
so this limit is equal to zero okay that
you can tap with that all right let's
think about what happens on the other
side okay so coming from the left of Y
so a value like say minus 0.1 what would
that mean up here
well it'll be two to the power of one of
our minus point one right which is to
the power of minus 10 what kind of
numbers that it's a very very small one
right so this is one over a thousand 24
and then the next one will be this is
minus point one as I'm getting closer to
zero but from backside it's going to be
2 to the power of world one over to the
power of hundred so in the first place
as I went from the right hand side the
whole denominator was skyrocketing so
therefore the whole thing got really
this one Mac has got beat denominator
but he what's happening when I'm
approaching from the other side
this thing is to the power of it becomes
its significant so if it becomes
insignificant what am I left with just
one
okay so what's this thing look like
as I'm pushing from the rise I said we
will get Costa zero
okay and it's gonna be doing something
like this it's gonna be coming up from a
bomb when I came from the left I was
approaching one right something like
that so what happens on the
how would you work it out
we're getting some asymptotic behavior
right there's no medical what can I tell
you you guys know how to find of our
asymptotes of rational functions this is
not a rational function right there's a
net of sorts
okay so what's happening as I put
enormous values of x in okay when X is
say a billion okay this we ^ one on a
million and then to the parent one on a
hundred million what's happening to it
it's getting closer to two to the power
of zero right isn't it that's what it's
approaching so this is to the power of 0
that's 1 so I've got 1 over 1 plus 1
which is 2 and you can go and verify and
the same thing will be happening on the
left hand side so if I have 0 right here
I've got one here we have a horizontal
axis right off y equals a huff okay so
the kind of behavior you've got looks
like this
that's messed up okay so what was my
point okay
this function is clearly not continuous
right but it has no vertical asymptotes
as a domain issue what does it equal to
here
it doesn't equal anything because you
can't substitute x equals zero if it
breaks it right
so therefore doesn't exist t doesn't
exist they're both open okay so sorry
that was a bit longer than I intended
but that's okay it still to illustrate
the point they're just continuous
functions they come in all shapes and
sizes
okay